I grew up on a farm and around farm
animals just used to being outside
running around barefoot and everything
in the New York is completely opposite
for that so it's been quite an
experience and I think I've grown a lot
from it it's been quite a journey I went
to a really small school so I think
everybody was pretty close to each other
I was aware that I was taller than
everybody else everybody would call me
like an Amazon or yeah just always I
feel looking up something I was always
the tallest one anything that it takes
me to a beach I love it
I just love to be around ocean I think
this summer I'm gonna try to get out of
New York with one smuggest and just kind
of relax and do a lot of fishing the
best way to approach a girl is just to
be funny right
even I know a lot of girls don't like
pickup lines but I think it's a really
cheesy pick-up line it's a beautiful
area so I think the best way just makes
it roll a comfortable it was the Carl's
jr. Texas barbecue thick burger
commercial that was a lot of fun I
actually had 70 burgers or something
like but in the commercial I'm like
washing is big at 30 50 truck and you
know eating a burger so I wouldn't say I
don't usually and I got a truck out of
it too where I'm from they got those
bowls nisi nose and then hang them from
the trailer hitch I'm like I'm not gonna
go that far though that's it don't much
hi I'm Hannah Ferguson and this is my G